a 1000 comió dos tercios de una barra de
caramelo vamos a dibujar esta barra de
caramelo y vamos a dividirla en tres
partes iguales al menos lo mejor que la
puedo dibujar y él se comió dos terceras
partes de esto aquí una tercera parte y
dos terceras partes
esto que estoy resaltando es la cantidad
que amir comió de caramelo después nos
dicen que nico comió dos tercios de una
barra de caramelo igual de ancha pero
más larga más larga así que es igual de
ancha vamos a dibujar la barra de
caramelo igual de ancha pero más larga y
él también comió dos terceras partes de
esta barra más larga así que va a ser
una barra más grande tiene el mismo
ancho pero es más larga y dos tercios de
esto vamos a dibujar los tercios y este
es un tercio y dos tercios lo que comió
niko bueno dos terceras partes de una
pieza más grande van a ser más grandes
que dos terceras partes de un pedazo más
pequeño esto de aquí la cantidad que
comió tiene el mismo ancho pero es más
larga que la de aquí arriba
y debido a que este es un pedazo del
mismo ancho pero más largo de caramelo
nico comió más caramelo veamos otro
problema mi unicornio vaya qué
interesante tengo un unicornio mi
unicornio comió dos sextas partes de una
pizza de la tienda y yo comí dos sextas
partes de una pizza diferente de la
tienda ve quién comió más pizza bueno
pues esto depende quizá la pizza de la
tienda a luce así y la pizza de la
tienda ve luce así
si este fuera el caso y esta es la pizza
de la tienda y esta otra la pizza de la
tienda ve si nos comemos dos sextos de
esta vamos a dividirla en seis partes
iguales lo mejor que podamos porque
luego es difícil dibujarlo asia en mano
dos sextos sería esto que estoy
sombreando y dos sextos de esta va a ser
vamos a dividirla también en seis partes
iguales lo más iguales que podamos hacer
las dos sextos de esto sería esto y esto
así que si la pizza de la tienda es más
grande que la pizza de la tienda
pues yo habré comido más pizza que mi
unicornio pero pudo haber sido el caso
contrario que ésta fuera la pizza de la
tienda ve y está más grande la pizza de
la tienda si esto fuera el caso entonces
mi unicornio sería el que comería más
pizza
o quizá las pizzas de ambas tiendas
tienen el mismo tamaño y de ser así
ambos habíamos comido exactamente la
misma cantidad pero aquí no nos dicen
cómo es la pizza de la tienda ni la
pizza de la tienda ve así que pues no
sabemos la respuesta es no sabemos
si mi unicornio o yo comemos más pizza
hagamos otro problema más que son
bastante divertidos
a giro le llevo un tercio de hora correr
de su casa a la escuela
a fred les llevo un tercio de hora
correr de su casa a la escuela aquí le
llevo más tiempo correr a la escuela en
este es un buen problema ya que nosotros
podríamos imaginar que bueno quizás hero
vive aquí voy a poner h de giro
se hace esta es la escuela trato de
dibujar un edificio más grande
la escuela
y no sé a lo mejor la casa de fred se
encuentra acá
o a lo mejor se encuentra acá
o incluso pues podría estar por acá
no sabemos dónde se encuentra en la casa
de fred y tampoco dónde se encuentra la
casa de hero no sabemos si está más
cercano a la escuela que la casa de hero
o al revés así que no sabemos y fíjense
que no nos están preguntando o no nos
están diciendo cuál casa de estos niños
se encuentra más cercana a la escuela y
tampoco nos dicen quién corre más rápido
nos dicen a quién le llevo más tiempo
correr a la escuela pero ellos nos están
diciendo directamente que tanto a giro
como fred les llevo un tercio de hora
correr a la escuela esta es la cantidad
de tiempo que les llevo no sabemos quién
corre más rápido o quién corre más lento
o si estaban a una distancia más cercana
o más lejana pero si sabemos que ambos
les llevo la misma cantidad de tiempo
correr de su casa a la escuela así que
esto es lo mismo a ambos les llevo la
misma cantidad de tiempo eso es muy
parecido a aquel famoso o problema que
preguntan qué pasa más un kilo de plomo
o un kilo de plumas
todo el mundo piensa bueno es que el
plomo pesa más que las plumas así que lo
lógico es que el plomo pesen más pero no
se están diciendo en el problema que es
un kilo de plomo o un kilo de plumas
ambos pesan un kilo así que ambos pesan
lo mismo y es muy parecido a lo que nos
plantean aquí